passage c'est le titre du film réalisé
par rené manzor avec alain delon et
francis lalanne comme producteur alain
delon revient ainsi dans un film
émouvant sur prenant complètement
inattendu je me garderai bien de
raconter
voici un extrait de la bande annonce
avant de retrouver alain delon
je n'ai qu'une femme faculté peuvent
célébrer ton change pas au programme des
discussions
georges adapté
john lannan a été mis de côté
il ya des trucs qui sont trop difficiles
à comprendre pour les adultes
les enfants alain delon bonsoir il faut
sauver pour ce film à christine boisson
jean luc moreau à la musique le petit
garçon qui est tout à fait étonnant le
réalisateur rené manzor et des frères la
lame
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est ce qui s'est
passé chez elle devant là qu'est ce qui
vous a poussée se disaient c'était
inattendu c'est une danse commune en
surprenant ce soutien du fantastique
psychologie je vois pas dans quel sens
vous devons et ce qui s'est passé il
s'est rien passé j'ai trouvé un sujet
absolument exceptionnel une équipe
fabuleuse l'équipe des frères lalanne et
dont le réalisateur rené et puis j'ai
plongé j'ai décidé de faire ce film il
s'est rien passé d'autre mais qu'est ce
qui vous a charmé dans cette histoire
qui encore une fois tient du chantage
aux besoins humains charme et il n'y a
pas de fantastique le fils est
fantastique vous avez l'air facile mais
bon si vous l'avez vu une armée c'est
quand association prônant l'inversé
c'est quand elle s'assure fans c'est
surprenant et parce que c'est surprenant
les fantastiques qui ne faut pas le dire
il ne faut pas le dévoiler
c'est un film que je ne vous raconterai
pas au risque de vous décevoir devoir
habiter parce que c'est un film qui ne
se raconte pas c'est un film qui ce qui
va se voir et c'est un film qui se
reçoit et je crois que c'est un film
bouleversant qui se classe donc que ces
ihu qui se reçoit pas ya des gens qui
vont être complètement réticents parce
qu'il faut rentrer dans cette histoire
dans ce même c'est bon je crois que
chacun y trouvera son compte et chacun
veut dire il trouvera sa partie et son
besoin est
à la fois d'expression et de réception
moi personnellement si vous voulez
j'espère que la comparaison ne choquera
pas certains je crois que ce film de
lait reçus et beaucoup de gens me l'ont
dit exactement comme un récital de brel
voyez la comparaison est énorme c'est à
dire que on en sort complètement brisée
a battu mais tellement heureux tellement
plein de joie tellement de pleins de foi
en l'avenir tellement plein de bonheur
est tellement plein d'heure de tout cela
il ya beaucoup de choses très
personnelles tension oui dans tous mes
films il ya des choses personnelles
dilma d'un fils à mon père il ya toute
l'histoire des relations entre un père
et un fils tracé oui parce que c'est une
merveilleuse histoire d'amour entre un
père et son fils et entre son fils et
son père et si j'ai dédié ce film vous
savez que j'ai pour principe pour
habitude pour envie de dédier tous mes
films et j'ai dédié ce film à mon fils
parce que c'est une histoire que
j'aurais souhaité vivre avec mon fils je
les dédie à mon père parce que c'est une
histoire que j'aurais aimé vivre avec
mon père et je crois que tous les pères
et tous les enfants du monde
s'identifieront et se retrouveront dans
cette histoire absolument je vous le dis
dans le microcosme des projections
privées qui ont eu lieu c'est déjà le
film événement je m'en réjouis de lire
la suite il ya une phrase alain delon
mettre en une seule image un seul dessin
toute la violence du monde ça peut vite
j'ai retenu sa de tête c'est un peu ce
que dit le héros que vous incarnez oui
pour tout à faire quelquefois
effectivement quand vous regardez la
télévision que vous gardez des journaux
de tweetie comme ça de rassembler toutes
les images de violence je l'aimerais
sans les comprimés puis à parler à
penser à autre chose c'est vrai
justement et surtout à penser autre
chose surtout à éviter la violence et
surtout à expliquer pourquoi on a assez
de violence et qui a eu d'autre chose de
plus belle et de plus intéressantes dans
le monde que de ce que que la violence
ils se mettent du mois se faire violence
pour éviter la violence
voilà vous êtes co producteurs vous ayez
donc décidé de mettre beaucoup d'argent
sur un jeune réalisateur il a 25 ans son
premier film vous avez complètement
renoncé être seulement interprète avec
un metteur en scène non je n'aime ou pas
non non je suis en général si vous les
coproducteurs parce que c'est plus
facile à monter les affaires mais
lorsque je fais par exemple notre
histoire je ne suis qu interprète et je
ne me considère que comme un interprète
là j'étais beaucoup plus concerné par ce
que là j'étais entouré d'une équipe
jeune qui avait besoin si vous voulez de
certains
le profiter certains de mes expériences
parce que jorge ait quand même une
certaine expérience du métier
donc c'est un travail en commun est un
travail d'équipé qui a donné ce que vous
avez vu claude et je sais que vous
l'avez apprécié vous êtes assez content
qu'il avait l'impression que vous avez
pas content je suis pas content je suis
heureux parce que ce film sera reçu
comme une sera reçue il plaira à
certains comme élite mois d'autres mais
je sais que de toute façon c'est un film
qui fera date et de toute façon c'est un
film événement qui tombe
je crois au bon moment et c'est un fils
et un film qui bouleversera quoi qu'il
arrive
merci alain delon d'avoir invité sa
météo